all right so if you've ever played any
sort of tactical shooter with an economy
system then chances are you know what it
means to save your gun when a round
isn't necessarily going your way
sometimes players will opt to go run and
hide so that they can keep their weapon
for the following round typically
players will prioritize saving
larger more impactful weapons because
they hold a higher value which can lead
to some pretty heroic clutches when all
you've got is a measly little pistol
and a dream yeah ah yeah
oh oh my god he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the orb i'm starting to
get nervous calling well above his years
clearing corners
you're an animal
heroic have done it and i just can't
believe it but in the world of valorant
one update back in 2020
changed
all of this in an effort to make the
game more exciting riot altered the
amount of money that players receive
when they save the hope was that it
would encourage players to go for that
sweet clutch and overall just make the
game more exhilarating for spectators
but did it actually work as intended
is saving worth it in ballarant
well today
we're gonna find out
[Applause]
all right so i know that most of you
league players out there probably don't
even consider saving in your valorant
ranked games
it's boring and weird and most of you
probably don't understand the benefits
of doing so
but should you you see back in october
of 2020 a valorent update was released
that changed the game's economy system
forever now it didn't change the prices
of any of the weapons but it did change
the amount of money that one could
receive after the end of a round this
update came only one month after riot
raised the price of the operator from 4
500 to 5 000 credits and also follow
changes to the maximum amount of credits
that a player could hold prior to these
changes valoran's pro scene looked a
hell of a lot different than what we
know today many teams would run double
op setups and once a team got a lead it
was pretty hard for their opponents to
make a comeback this was back in the
heyday of ct sided split where if you
got two to four rounds on attack
you were happy with a credit cap of 12
000 credits it was
extremely easy for a team to just
run away with a match so let me break
down how things used to look when you
saved before these two patches if you
saved your gun on defense and your
opponents managed to detonate the spike
then you would receive 1900 credits the
following round attackers who lost but
survived the round without detonating
the spike would also receive 1900 if you
have somebody like yay or cnet on your
team then you're sure as [ __ ] saving
that operator but in patch 1.11 riot
wanted to make players reconsider this
choice after the update players who
saved on defense but lost the round due
to the spike detonating now only
received a thousand credits and the same
went for attackers who saved without
planting the bomb now if you believe in
your chances of going for that one vx
clutch and you have enough to buy for
the following round
then fit you should probably go for it
which is exactly how riot wanted you to
think after the update prior to the
release of the patch valorem's co-lead
game designer or kane spoke to ryan
central and this was his reasoning
behind the change we always want players
driving towards action and driving
towards like their objectives and these
are generally speaking lighter touch
changes they're not super heavy
they shouldn't feel very punitive but
it's it's more about encouraging players
to
have to make hard decisions in certain
scenarios where they might just default
to
saving their gun so what riot is really
saying here is they got sick of watching
y'all rat in corners and farm exit frags
and wanted to punish you for saving in
certain situations the question of
course is how exactly does this change
make valorant differ from the godfather
of tac fps economies counter-strike and
is it an upgrade to what we deal with in
cs now both valorant and cs include the
crucial pistol round which we actually
covered in a previous episode of cracked
you should totally go check it out if
you haven't already but beyond the
pistol round there are actually a lot of
differences between both games
respective economies first off cs go's
economic system is just deeper and more
complex you get bonus amounts of money
for each kill depending on which weapon
you are using while in valorant you only
receive a fixed 200 credits for each and
every kill this is why knifing someone
invalorent is
genuinely kind of pointless in cs it
nets you like half a rifle invalorant it
nets you
a toxicity report but where the games
really start to distance themselves from
one another is with respect to lost
bonus you see invalorant a team can
achieve max loss bonus after only three
rounds after a single round loss you
receive 1900 credits and after two
consecutive round losses you receive
2400 credits once you lose three
straight your loss bonus caps out at
2900 credits but in cs go lost bonuses
range anywhere from fourteen hundred to
thirty four hundred dollars and 5
consecutive losses are needed to hit the
max loss bonus
of course with a higher money cap and
overall longer games i think this makes
sense what this means is that in cs when
your economy breaks it can completely
change the game getting e-code is even
more of a disaster and when your money
is like really up
you feel really far ahead but saving on
t side in counter-strike is very
unforgiving if you save and lose the
round due to the time running out then
you will not receive any sort of loss
bonus at all and there's a reason for
that not only is the point of t-side to
attack but crucially
the weapons are cheaper the biggest
difference between cs and valorant is
that whereas valorance by menu is
mirrored across both sides
css constitute in such a way that each
side has access to different weapons
and it just so happens that the ct side
is on the whole a shitload more
expensive cts famously have to fork up
either 2 900 or 3 100 for an m4 while
tees can secure an ak for only 2 700.
mollies are also 600 dollars for cts but
400 for teas just as the mp9 is 1250.
but the mac ten only a thousand and
fifty overall these economic differences
make saving on defense not only much
more common in counter-strike than
invalorant but downright necessary hell
there are times when ct's have to double
save which is something that we just
don't see in riot shooter not to mention
that half buys and eco rounds feels
significantly more winnable in valorant
guns like the frenzy and spectre are
still pretty busted which allows teams
to pull off thrifty rounds that you just
don't really see in cs go they were on
spectres this was gonna be uh hard
around for them to convert but marco's
making a go of this hold on
now marco out does a rifle apparently
this is still not over yet oh b what is
happening economy plays a much less like
dominant role in valor because of you
know the lower cap and then the the fact
that you never have to double save
thrifties are absolutely insane so
another reason why pistol rounds aren't
so important in valerian is because
i've seen so many thrifties in polar and
you don't see that many ecos in cs go
you don't see that like it's very like
how often you see glocks win against aks
but in this game classics are the best
thing to ever exist
uh the frenzy is busted the ghost
against rifles is really good too don't
even get me started on sheriffs unless
you're saving for an operator valerian
players are essentially able to buy
every other round which does in a sense
make the game more exciting to watch
overall we see fewer rounds where a team
gets absolutely rolled because they only
have pistols or smgs and hard economic
resets just aren't nearly as common as
they are in counter-strike and in
valorant hero rifles have proven to be
extremely effective against full buys
last year run it back a valorent
analytics and news site posted some
stats regarding the success rate of
teams who purchased a single rifle now
i'll be honest this post features a lot
of numbers and it's kind of hard to look
at because it's valorant so i figured
there's nobody better tasked to break it
down for us
than my boy colton
sorry dude and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about sorry
what do you mean i've written tons of
code to do statistical analysis just for
fun so this is
oh god
i really am a turbo dork aren't i
well i guess we'll just break these
numbers down one section at a time first
where did they come from that would be
courtesy de mars de rover an analyst for
nrg with a history of collating
statistical data from the internet the
data on more than 3 000 rounds of pro
play comes from run it back gg and their
2d replay feature which is actually
super neat should go check it out it
goes without saying that demars is a
pretty smart guy so even though i
haven't seen all the raw data for myself
i think we're in pretty safe hands here
so without further ado let's take a look
at the graphs demars broke the different
buy options into seven categories if you
want to see the most popular buy options
and their corresponding win rates in
each category they're all in the graphic
so definitely check that out if you want
some more depth on each of these each
round in these statistics is against a
team with a full buy at least five
vandals or phantoms and optional
operators or odin's from the attacking
side we see a pretty steady increase in
win rate as you give the attackers more
firepower that seems pretty obvious what
is very interesting is that we get
dangerously close to a 50 win rate with
only two primary rifles and hit that
mark before we actually get to a full
buy one thing i've seen mentioned on
reddit and twitter with this data is the
use of agent abilities especially
ultimates helping to influence this
number which certainly holds a lot of
merit but dimitri is going to talk more
about that later i think it also
underscores just how useful guns like
the spectre and sheriff can really be in
the right hands even against rifles now
you might be thinking what's up with the
win rate being higher with one or two
less rifles on the team and that's where
those little lines at the end of the
graph come in they're called error bars
and saving you all the math for how
they're actually calculated they show
how confident we can be in a particular
statistic no matter how large your
sample size is it will always be just
that a sample size the smaller the
sample size the less confident we can be
that the data is an accurate
representation of the real world even
with this margin for error it's clearly
still not a massive hit to the attacking
team's chances in the next round if you
lose your vandal and are forced back to
something like the spectre at least in
pro play on the defending side we see a
decline in the pistol save wins versus a
full buy as well as a much sharper
increase once you start adding smgs and
a hero rifle or two actually surpassing
a 50 win rate which just goes to show
the defender-sided nature of tactical
shooters but another possible factor to
this is that the defenders have a little
more flexibility than the attackers to
choose angles and gunfights that better
suit their current loadout to help get
the most out of something like the
spectre or judge the point from earlier
around agent abilities making up for a
lack of rifles also stands on defense as
well so does all this data mean you
should just be throwing caution to the
wind and going for that clutch every
time instead of saving your rifle
well no obviously not but it does show
that if your team is sitting around 11
000 credits then you should be able to
put together a very competitive buy the
next round which may make the option to
try and fish for even one extra kill all
the more enticing and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about but despite being more fun for us
the viewers we decided to ask the pros
what they think
did riot's update back in 2020 really
change the way that they view the game
before i felt like everyone would go for
every scenario so
even if it was like a 2v5 3v5 they would
always go for it because they know
they're going to be rich the next round
but i figured lately more people are
saving and it's obviously a smarter
choice because i know there's a stat
that says if three or more people have
guns like the success rate of a round is
basically the same so yeah i do believe
that
with that update saving should be taken
more seriously like you shouldn't go for
every scenario like a 3v5 or even 3v4 if
someone's low then you shouldn't go for
it and just save but for other players
they didn't really notice a difference
in their saving habits i think if you're
gonna save you're either saving because
you have enough money to buy somebody
else on your team who doesn't have
enough the next round or you're like
like next round you're gonna save anyway
so or like
like low buy like eco round
and then you just have that extra gun
it's like a hero rifle that you could
possibly pop off and win the round so i
don't really think it changed much
honestly now ranked is obviously a much
different environment compared to pro
play but there is one thing that's
static across both of them and it's
something we haven't really touched on
yet
alt economy each and every agent in
valor and has their own unique ultimate
ability that can either help set up
their team for success or maybe just net
them a couple of kills
and for certain agents like jet or
chamber their alts can actually replace
the need to even buy rifles which can
massively impact their team's economy if
you're in a situation where only three
or four members of your team can afford
to buy a gun and you have your alts
please be a good teammate drop a rifle
and use your ultimate this allows your
team to have many more competitive buys
even an agent like reyes can buy a
frenzy and alt and have just as much
impact on a round as if they'd bought a
rifle and there goes whippy though okay
needs to respond that's a great response
so far two more players to go he's got
one bullet left in the tour de force and
there's two players oh he's found it oh
he gets the door for the round the red
ball clutch out of el diablo so is
saving actually worth it in balance we
know that riot went out of their way to
give players more incentive to go for
those sick clutches but
the impact may not have been as
universal as they'd intended saving guns
or going for clutches is and always will
be
situational if your team is in a
position where they can still afford to
buy guns the following round
then you might as well go for it what we
do know is because of the economy and
ultimates in this game they're gonna be
able to purchase weapons pretty often
and the stats show that you should be
buying at least something nearly every
round whether it's a proper rifle or
just an upgraded pistol is up to you
but you can do some real damage with
nearly
any weapon invalorant
so get out there and start shooting
i was gonna say like it serves no other
invalorant it serves no other purpose
other than
cheesing off
the guy you
you know the guy you knife which i guess
in a sense does serve a purpose right
like you do get you do shock they're
mental like you definitely chalk a
dude's mental if you knife them you
don't get it
they lose something yeah a piece of
themselves the problem is
which let's be honest they don't have
much left no if they're a valerian
player man they don't really yeah
there's not much left a league player
who switched to valorent
that's the nice poor bastard
clap